[Applause]
[Music]
guys its 750 750 the only reason we
would ever wake up this early fall into
the Shedd Aquarium the Shedd Aquarium
this aquarium in the Midwest maybe
America is gigantic it's awesome it's
very expansive it really behind the
scenes sneak peek look at otters
penguins trees bats my name is michael
pratt i am a trainer with the marine
mammal department and you guys are here
to experience our trainer for a day so
people can actually have the degrees as
well absolutely they throw on a pair of
rubber boots just like you guys got on
and they follow a trainer around for
about four hours and they get to
experience kind of the highlights of
what we do every day and we also want to
inspire people to work towards
conservation so checking these animals
out in the wild all right let's do this
let's get right to it so this is the
marine mammal kitchen it's pretty much
the the busiest place in our department
and we usually hand sort through all the
food right now these are guys are
sorting through some clam for our sea
otters it's also really important for us
to find sustainable seafood to feed our
animals we go through about 800 pounds
of restaurant quality food to feed all
of our animals every single day so we
are gonna be sorting through this clamp
so you can grab a piece clam pull off
this top part this is the the foot or
the stomach and this is what most of
their diet is made up of it actually
cost the same amount of money to feed an
adult sea otter as it does to feed an
adult beluga whale that's a 40 to 60
pound animal versus that close to 2,000
pound animal this is look how Kings eat
though yeah they have the animal
boys and testers all the trainers on for
us to make sure
[Music]
look at us like who the hell are you
losers holy crap this one loves you Jen
probably just touched poop oh I don't
care what see yourself
[Laughter]
so the vocalizing because it's a bunch
of new people out here they want to let
themselves be known they actually used
penguin vocalizations to create some of
the dinosaur noises in Jurassic Park
cookie is a very important penguin here
at said she will be turning 30 years old
this year cookie actually recently had
cataract surgery oh my god so do you
hang out with these guys every day so
I've been working with them for about
seven and a half years so I know them
really well they know me really well got
a good relationship so one of the really
important things for animals here at
Chad is environmental enrichment
providing changes to their environment
to keep them stimulated these are some
environmental enrichment devices also -
toys let's grab a couple of pieces of
food stick them in there so we're gonna
do is give these to Ellie our youngest
daughter oh hi there you go oh wow
so it keeps their minds active you know
they got to work to figure it out but
it's not just moving today
so the Otto's it takes a little while
for them to learn which way to push it
but she she knows what to do where do
these daughters come from like what are
their stories
well here site we have five sea otters
and four of them were directly rescued
from wild they were orphaned so are
somehow separated from their mother so
one of those things about working with
the animals here I've said is it gives
us the skills that we can use to help
animals out in the wild this is Luna and
Mari oh my gosh I would just hang out
here all day if I were to feel like I'm
otter girl sea otters actually have the
densest fur of any mammal because unlike
most marine mammals they don't have a
thick layer of blubber to keep them warm
so they're relying on their coat it's
also one of the reasons that they eat so
much food too is because their
metabolism runs so fast to keep up a
high body temperature these are some of
the treats that we give the Otters just
clam mix up with water and put it in
some little molds and freeze it oh they
knew you know I mean absolutely I toss
it in there just don't do your hands too
close here you go
they will start to stash them in a
little pocket that they have under their
forelimbs they're really intelligent
animals these have a really short
attention span they get bored from the
user fair enough
highly intelligent loading his band I'm
the beluga whale made me not do anything
it was absolutely phenomenal it was like
the coolest thing we could have done one
thing you just don't realize is how much
these people love the animals that they
work with they did tell us a lot about
their conservation efforts and how they
try to use their research specifically
to like foster better rescue and
rehabilitation of like orphaned animals
or animals that are sick I wish we got
to touch the otters but I understand
that they are fragile gentle creatures
and sometimes just look you don't touch
[Music]